all time great traveler no [ __ ] that
would be the best moment on vlog history
I'm talking [ __ ] let's go to the counter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
vlog here we are
it is 906 in the morning Wednesday we
lost all Tuesday you and I yep we lost
on Tuesday we'll get back Thursday
Friday we got Friday anyway nonetheless
it's the beginning of the end of this
ridiculous trip which is in the last
week I've gone from New York to Oslo
to Copenhagen to Moscow to LA to
Brisbane to Sydney to Melbourne back to
the Kinect and Dubai to New York that's
a lot of [ __ ] travel but a whole lot
of accomplishments the complex episode
did you watch the complex who did that
video it really good really good I hope
you checked out that episode got a lot
done got a lot of vaynermedia meetings
in a lot of culture hacking and some
great speeches and some great friends in
all these countries so here's the
beginning of the what are we here for
140 first 36 hours three locations in
Australia epic like efforts so I'm
excited chose ACK that's Zach he's
attractive but he's being inappropriate
with scheduling me this hardcore you
know Zach have you ever have you ever
heard of the marathon versus the sprint
I mean you're gonna kill the Golden
Goose here see how a bushes remind me
ain't Arabic for you months ago you know
supposedly I'll remember you coming
story but faced with a magic you were
super good-looking no see I remember
remember I told you I remember about the
destroy Australian faces hey it's Gary
um call me back I just want to discuss
this position and make sure everybody's
aligned on it and and talk it through
you guys over communicating I'll make a
call on Monday so love you give me a
call see ya bye
from getting myself hyped for a pre
speech to addressing operational issues
at vaynermedia this shicken go real fast
back and forth stuff can change up real
quick by the way real fun fact I adore
pairs
I think pairs are stunningly underrated
do you agree
[Music]
one of everybody's dairy be super
excited to be hitting this page and
second
babban on the ones and twos
super-interested have no idea what I may
be talking about that is just basically
the way I roll
improv from the beginning till the end
every time and
[Applause]
I think that there's way too many people
in this audience that are in the excuse
business IVA and yeah and it's it's
tough because I'm empathetic there's
always things you know you could have
two parents that were drug addicts you
could have lost your parents in a car
accident when you were a kid you could
have had your money stolen to you by a
partner there's so many things that
happen in life I'm super empathetic to
it the ultimate problem is though is
that the market the world doesn't care
like it's really interesting to me life
is pretty binary it's either black or
white it's either yes or no and the one
that matters to me the most is you're
either on the offense in your life right
now or you're on the defense you're
either coming up with reasons why not
all this technology all this stuff but
why not or why yes all this technology
all this stuff you're looking at things
and you're making a decision more
importantly being a successful
entrepreneur is a skill set right and
it's one that comes natural to some and
others not as much it's a fun thing to
be right now and everybody wants to and
the opportunity is very real I'm a great
entrepreneur but I think I'm even better
at consumer behavior and psychology it's
Who I am it's why a lot of you follow me
because when you cut me down you see
that I'm pushing positivity and a whole
lot of other things that matter and
trying to get people to do it the right
way be patient do the right thing do the
death my friends you need to get
yourself in the right place mentally and
then you need to get yourself in the
right place mentally because the thing
that people have now wrapped their head
around is that this takes a lot of work
like a lot a lot not a little something
and if you aspire let me just ground
this if you think you're gonna make a
million dollars a year which is funny
the way people throw that out like
everybody gets there almost nobody gets
there right if you want to make five
hundred thousand dollars a year which
you'd put you in the distal portion top
1% of income getters here in Australia
if you want to make $100,000 a year and
like doing it and it's on your terms and
it's your life
it takes a lot of work and it takes a
lot of smart work the thing I talk a
whole lot about is
the thing I talk less about is being
smart because I don't think that brings
you any value so what I do is I try to
come and speak or through my actions
show you the smart things that I'm doing
and then remind you that it's still hard
work the framework is simple this is
simple you may have not allowed yourself
to have the honest conversation with
yourself of how much hard work and how
much patience it takes to be successful
but it doesn't change the fact that
that's the case you've never met anybody
in your life who has a work that are
faced off for a long time that's built
something significant it makes seem that
it happened fast cuz they're 27 but
maybe they've been hustling since they
were 13 in a different way that gave
them 14 years of experience to be a
winner in that game and so please please
wrap your head around what we're
actually doing here and more importantly
if you were smart enough to be here
today and I mean this the fact that you
came here today puts you so far ahead of
everybody else and I hate knowing for a
fact that so many of you are gonna give
up your advantage because you like
hearing me say it and you like the way
it feels but then you leave and you
don't do anything about it so please
Brisbane do me a favor go do something
about this talk today I implore you it
will change the course of your career
thank you
nice and solid put up blog
babban and I successful so far
good stop on the way to Sydney good
energy good talks good stuff good life
[Music]
I got one the Vayner part output in the
production world at a lower cost all
time great traveler no [ __ ] that would
be the best moment blog history I'm
talking [ __ ] let's go to the cash
after Sydney
[Music]
you know different city same back a big
conversation me and babban uh now on our
way to our city talks weather's
beautiful it's a beautiful city overall
your process have you trip I bet hi how
are you
very nice now what this is gone this way
you go Australia holiday to get Israel
they all know how I wrong
I'm sure you recognize me haha that's
awesome I love the back I want to do
something different thank you I think
I'm excited for the pleasure thank you
me it's amazing they make this a lot of
famous people already people's nice Oh
highly of you are backstage which is not
always the case most pieces thank you
for saying that
[Music]
I've literally got done just saying in
Melbourne in Brisbane that my entire
focus is what people say behind my back
yeah and to have you say that well
because you know we've all I mean I
think yes people for 20 years yours and
you get a real read on there it's very
different I hurt and became hurt heavy I
appreciate you saying there
thanks for saying zero ego and thank you
for saying that
thank you appreciate it I'm extremely
optimistic
I'm extremely positive what's going on
and it's all because of the framework of
this talk this thing you have to how
many can you do not have a cell phone
raise your hand cool zero by the way for
anybody in the front rows this thing is
ridiculously powerful this thing is the
remote control of our society this thing
has eliminated every excuse out of your
[ __ ] mouth because if you have to
work 9 to 6 to pay the bills to pay your
dues to pay your debts that is exactly
right and appropriate everybody comes
from different starting points I have
unbelievable of empathy to that the
exciting thing though is that our
grandparents didn't have this thing they
had a work 96-97 and then there was only
so much upside that they could create
for themselves long term from 7:00 to
2:00 in the morning
this thing has fundamentally changed
everything and I just think we take it
for granted
I really wish everybody understood the
power that's literally sitting in their
hands right now this is literally a
media creation and distribution tool
that would have cost tens of millions of
dollars if you understand distribution
the technology probably cost 20 thousand
dollars you know 25 years ago cameras
they said fine the distribution you
would have a shoot a satellite into
space you would have had a bio printing
press you would have had a buy trucks
you would have had done so much the fact
that every person here
can literally turn this on themselves
create content around something that are
interested in and then have platforms
like YouTube and Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter and LinkedIn distributed let
me remind you at no cost is so batshit
crazy for all of us old [ __ ] in here
that I just wish people would not take
it for granted and so my friends I come
here tonight to really try to pull up
one move can I actually take somebody
even if they're a huge fan
where if they've never heard of me
before and tweaked their perspective on
what's actually going on can I convince
one of you that nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your headaches and problems and
when you complain you're just taking
minutes off the board and energy of the
board from doing something about it
literally I am fascinated by the
inability to be held accountable I am
fascinated that you actually are coming
up and spending energy and trying to say
why you're not successful because your
older brother did some [ __ ] in 1996 and
so self-awareness and humility and
empathy and all these warm and fuzzy
things that grandma talks about happen
to be the biggest secrets in the
rough-and-tumble game of business I
highly recommend you get in touch with
those emotions thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
all right now really lose your [ __ ]
minds here we go go
love you guys thank you
my pleasure really good
I see how are you good how are you you
enjoyed it yes I did love everything you
do I was great thank you
you shook your head on a certain point
early on yes fun if it was about tripped
or something there's something and I saw
you and I was like he gets it
oh he's not underpriced I said
everything's priced appropriately her
over price and you shook your head I was
like he gets it yeah take care of it
that's a good one okay stop can we stop
for a second yeah I'll hop out for a
second hi what up B G what I said yeah
yeah I'm sure you got that because I'm
not sure how good was that
do you like the shoutout see ya see ya
see ya bye guys love you guys doing the
right thing is always the right thing
yeah yeah I'm a quart fat man what do
you think give us a little recap big day
hello la to Brisbane
no twisting Sydney I'll take over here
BAM you say behind the camera
alright great day got a lot done big
themes mindset of execution clouds and
[ __ ] dirt [ __ ] clouds and
dirt
[Music]